ein tag im freibad das ist der kleine
urlaub direkt vor der haustür eigentlich
tatsächlich ist das längst gewalt
schauen sie auf diese freibad bilder
über die deutschland heute spricht
eine massenschlägerei wird das überall
männer zwischendrin noch hilflose
security-mitarbeiter da in den kescher
10 sie die und hinten sehen sie auch
noch frauen und familien gleich im bild
die sich und ihre kinder da in
sicherheit bringen dann fliegen die
fäuste die situation wird zunehmend
unübersichtlich mehr als 100 männer sind
an dieser schlägerei beteiligt die
angeblich mit einer wasserpistole
begonnen hat
ein tag im freibad in diesem fall ist
dass das sommerbad am insulaner in
berliner süden in steglitz ist das und
die bilanz dieses tages 13 streifenwagen
im einsatz und teile einer
einsatzhundertschaft
mittlerweile ermittlungen wegen
körperverletzung gegen jugendliche gegen
junge männer darüber über diese szenen
aus dem freibad müssen wir sprechen
freibäder die für familien ganz offenbar
wie hier in diesen szenen zu no go areas
werden und zugeschaltet rainer wendt der
chef der deutschen polizeigewerkschaft
schönen guten morgen herr wendt das
kommt nicht völlig überraschend
diese szenen darüber reden wir im grunde
seit jahren ist das mittlerweile ein
ganz normaler tag in den deutschen in
der berliner freibad ja glücklicherweise
ist es das nicht es kommt nicht an jedem
tag zu solchen szenen aber leider immer
wieder wir sprechen ja seit jahren
darüber dass vor allem junge männer
glauben sich doch auf diese weise
ausbauen zu können und ich frage mich
natürlich wie es überhaupt dazu kommen
kann dass so viele dieser klientel
überhaupt in ein solches schwimmbad
hineingelassen werden das ist aufgabe
des veranstalters die person kontrollen
vorzunehmen und auch zu steuern und
notfalls zu begrenzen jetzt schauen wir
noch mal genau in diese szenen reihen
wir haben da ein paar kringel drum
gemacht denn mich bewegt vor allen
dingen bei freibad ja was ist wo man mit
der familie hingeht wo man mit den
kindern hin geht schauen wir dass wir da
im hintergrund eben noch familien sehen
hinter all diesen ändern die da rein
gelassen wurden und prügeln sehen wir
hinten eben auch familien sehen wir
frauen hier sehen wir die männer einmal
eingekreist aber hinten frauen mit
kindern also würden sie im moment sagen
dass zumindest ab den nachmittagsstunden
dass der logo areas im grunde sind für
familien mit kleinen kindern
dazu darf es nicht kommen denn wir
dürfen diesen gewaltbereiten schläger
nicht den öffentlichen raum überlassen
es ist ja nicht nur dieses eine
schwimmer wir sind auch viele
öffentliche plätze wo wir das in diesem
jahr wieder erleben werden wie im
vergangenen jahr auch in den jahren
davor übrigens auch in parkanlagen in
zwei bin dann überall versuchen diese
jungen männer den öffentlichen raum für
sich einzunehmen und zu festzustellen
hier sind wir und wir bestimmen hier wo
es lang genau erwähnt herr wenn das ist
doch längst passiert also das ist ja
jetzt etwas worüber wir vor zwei vor
drei jahren also vor der korona krise
massiv berichtet haben hierbei gilt
jetzt der erste richtig heißen sommertag
und dieselben szenen immer wir haben
immer wieder wir haben von den fällen in
kaufbeuren gehört und andere szenen aus
großen freibädern in anderen städten
gesehen und jetzt eben hier in berlin
also könnten sie aus freiem herzen einer
familie sagen willkommen zurück im
berliner sommerbad im insulaner am
nächsten sonntag angesichts dieser zehn
ehrlich gesagt könnte ich das nicht wenn
die betreiber nach wie vor nicht bereit
und nicht in der lage sind den zugang zu
diesen bildern ordentlich zu steuern das
kann man machen das kann jeder
diskothekenbesitzer der nord-spd der
kann dafür sorgen dass solche
krawallmacher die man da kennt man and
wie sie kreativ die müssen dann halt
draußen bleiben und genau das muss ein
veranstalter und da kann nicht jedes mal
die polizei kommen die polizei ist eine
strafverfolgungsbehörde wir sind kein
bademeister klopp und können nicht in
allen freibädern mit hundertschaften
präsent sein das ist aufgabe der
veranstalter das zu regeln aber wir
hätten sind dann nicht reingelassen also
dann können sie ja können sie fast das
freibad zu machen das sind ja hunderte
da hätten sie dann davor gestanden mit
der security die gibt es ja seit jahren
hin berliner freibädern weil man weiß
dass man ein gewaltproblem hat in diesen
freibädern das heißt die stehen davor
und lassen diese 100 männer alle nicht
rein ins freibad ja ganz genau so ist
dass das wird bei jeder diskothek
gemacht da wird entschieden und zwar von
demjenigen der das aus recht ausübt du
kommst hier rein kommst hier nicht rein
das ist eigentlich ganz einfach man muss
es einfach nur machen und in diesem fall
ist noch als besonders einfach gewesen
denn es sollte ja ein familienfest sein
es sollte ein fest für kinder und
familien sein da hätte man mit guter
begründung sagen müssen diese gruppen
junger männer kommen wir nicht ran aber
aber wie wollen sie das feststellen her
wenn das interessiert mich schon also
ich bin für alles was sicherheit bringt
wie machen sie aber diese
gesichtskontrolle am eingang ja genau so
muss man das sehen wie jeder
diskothekenbesitzer dass meine tür steht
auf macht das wird allgemein akzeptiert
derjenige der das gericht hat der muss
auch nicht begründen warum jemand nicht
ran de steen einfach mit rein punkt
warum sie sagen das ist die aufgabe der
freibäder aber kriegt auch die politik
das nicht in griff also wir haben diese
politische debatte gehabt hier vor zwei
vor drei jahren als wir ähnliche
vorfälle vor allen dingen auch damals in
düsseldorf gehabt haben hießen
deutschlandweite diskussion auch um mehr
sicherheit in den städten in den
freibädern die politik kriegt das nicht
in griff auch weil sie möglicherweise
selbst nicht in freibäder geht erstens
ist und zweitens weil es die
veranstalter sind die politik schaut
natürlich die debatte um das thema
kreativ dass wir hier auch ganz
offensichtlich sehen es sind junge
männer nicht alle aber die meisten die
allermeisten von ihnen mit einem
migrationshintergrund die ganz
offensichtlich diesen öffentlichen raum
für sich beanspruchen das haben wir am
gardasee erlebt das erleben wir in
stuttgart in den parkanlagen in anderen
großstädten die politik sollte diese
diskussion weil dies auch eine folge der
zuwanderungspolitik war an der jahre ist
und diese diskussion mit dem deutschland
niemand führen im gegenteil wer sie auch
nur anzettelt wird sofort als
rassistisch des schirms rainer wendt
führt diese diskussion und wir führen
sie hier mit ihm bei bild live zu diesen
prügelszenen dieser massenschlägerei im
freibad in diesem fall in berlin sie
sind stellen sie frei sind freibäder
inzwischen den no go area darüber
sprechen wir jetzt hier ist er auch
schon peter harzheim dem präsidenten des
bundesverbands deutscher schwimmer schön
dass sie hier bei uns sind sie sind
sozusagen deutschlands oberster
bademeister haben auch diese szenen
sehen und wir fragen uns hier wie groß
ist das gewaltproblem in den
schwimmbädern oder
erschüttert nicht erst mal gut schön und
morgen in die runde jetzt erschüttert
mich damit diese bilder wieder sehen die
haben wir vor der korona waren wir schon
mal gehabt und zwar wurde sein
düsseldorfer und die kehl am rhein in
anderen orten auch viele gewalttaten
verzeichnet
ich kenne hier nicht mehr von hormonen
sprechen die das vielleicht ein bisschen
anders spielen
es ist eine entwicklung die mir ein
bisschen zu denken was hatte ich damals
schon angefangen hat als ich gesagt habe
ich habe sorge dass demnächst noch ohne
security in ein freibad gehen können
aber die security gibt es ja hier in
berlin längst die sehen wir ja auch da
auf den bildern aus steglitz ahlen in
weißen t-shirts die ist ja schon da und
das ist genau die reaktion auf das was
sie gerade gesagt haben dass wir nämlich
schon seit jahren darüber diskutieren
hier sehen was noch mal eingekreist also
das sind ja die männer davon der
privaten sicherheit und trotzdem ist für
sicherheit ganz offenbar auch in diesem
schwimmer zumindest nicht zu sorgen
wenn ich 40 jahre zurückdenke dann hier
habe ich einen freiheit zusammen da sind
wir mit unseren eltern mit familien
genau das war noch schön unheimlich
leider hat sie diese zeit ein bisschen
verändert zu mehr geben wobei ich das
wort respekt marine mund nehme die
person die ich dort sehe im moment haben
keinen respekt mehr vor anderen leuten
und wenn ich dann auch noch zum
aussprechen dass ich hier vorwiegend
läuft und mit migrationshintergrund sehe
also auch verschiedene kulturelle leben
dann muss ich sagen das kann so nicht
weitergehen würden sie aber noch
reingehen hatte martin meister wenn herz
an wenn sie deine bademeister wären in
diesem schwimmbad dort am insulaner in
berlin steglitz würden sie die in dieser
szene noch reingehen oder würden sie
sagen also das ist eine nummer zu groß
er für mich also das ist für mich auch
persönliche nummer zu groß hier muss wie
gesagt auch die politik ein bisschen
renner wie muss die badbetreiber in
einer form mehr unterstützen indem sie
also auch nicht immer die leute die
jetzt einfach mal herausgefiltert werden
dort die die straftaten begehen nach
zwei stunden wieder freigelassen sondern
dass sie wirklich eine strafe bekommen
und dass sie da auch unter zweigen und
nicht nur weil es bekannten sind und
wieder sagen oder dürfte ich bin
geschockt viele dieser person rücksicht
bringen dass sie uns in diese bilder
gemeinsam noch einmal ganz genau
anschauen werden diese prügelei diese
massenschlägerei im vordergrund läuft
sieht man im hintergrund
familien die eilig hier sehen wir doch
mal die security die weißen t-shirt die
versuchen dort irgendwie ruhe
reinzubringen hin und her geschubst
werden und im hintergrund sehe dann
familien die alle ihre sachen
zusammenpacken teilweise mit kleinen
kindern auf dem arm die nur versuchen
dort raus zu kommen können sie ganz
reinen gewissens sagen nächsten sonntag
hier sehen wir für mich den kleine
kinder mit ja so klein wasserpistolen in
der hand die dazwischen drin am rande
dieser massenschlägerei stehen können
sie diesen kindern diesen familien guten
gewissens sagen machen sie das kommt die
nächsten sonntag wieder ab in frage nein
nein das kann ich nicht guten gewissens
sagen dann wenn ich diese bilder sehe
dann traue es mir schon ich habe selber
drei enkelkinder im auto von 7 5 und 8
monaten und wenn ich damit rein gehen
würde würde ich unverantwortlich handeln
hier müssen auch die betreibung wie
schon erwähnt ein bisschen aktiver
werden die leute aus dem batliner dabei
müssen auch mal das risiko eingehen dass
sie nicht so viele leute erinnern aber
hier sollte man schon wer eigentlich in
selektieren und hat eben die justiz
sollte die kollegen oder wie
badbetreiber ein bisschen mehr
unterstützen indem sie auch wirklich
strafen verhängen die also auch
vollzogen werden und nicht immer wie
schon gesagt du wirst du und dann war es
das gewesen deutschlands oberster
bademeister der hierbei bild live sagt
er würde da im moment seine enkelkinder
nicht ins bad lassen ins freibad
schicken wir müssen noch mal konkreter
über diese kontrollen sprechen herr
harzheim wir haben vor einer stunde hier
mit rainer wendt gesprochen dem chef der
polizeigewerkschaft und der hat
folgendes gesagt er hat gesagt er
wünscht sich gesichtskontrolle wie vor
der disco dort an den eingängen der
freibäder
also wenn die betreiber nach den songs
nicht wir wollen einmal ganz kurz
reinhören und dann sprechen wir darüber
harzheim in den in den satz von rainer
wendt
wenn die betreiber nach wie vor nicht
bereit und nicht in der lage sind den
zugang zu diesen bildern ordentlich zu
steuern das kann man machen das kann
jeder diskothekenbesitzer werden ob die
sp hat der kann dafür sorgen dass solche
krawallmacher die man ja kennt man diese
kreativ die müssen dann halt draußen
bleiben das wird bei jeder diskothek
gemacht da wird entschieden und zwar von
demjenigen der das aus recht ausübt du
kommst du kommst hier nicht rein das ist
eigentlich ganz einfach man muss es
einfach nur machen und in diesem fall
ist noch ganz besonders einfach gewesen
denn es sollte ja ein familienfest sein
es sollte ein fest für kinder und
familien sein da geht man mit guter
begründung sagen müssen diese gruppen
junger männer kommen wir nicht ran aber
aber wie wollen sie das feststellen her
wenn das interessiert mich schon also
ich bin für alles was sicherheit bringt
wie machen sie aber diese
gesichtskontrolle am eingang ja genau so
muss man das sehen wie jeder
diskothekenbesitzer dass meine tür steht
auf macht das wird allgemein akzeptiert
derjenige der das gericht hat der muss
auch nicht begründen warum jemand nicht
rein das ist ihnen einfach nicht rein
also einlasskontrollen damit zu einer
art türsteher wird hier gefordert der
hat sein wie finden sie das wie sollte
man da auch entscheiden du darfst du nie
das ist sehr sehr schwierig bei der
disco oder in der wahl bin ich privat
betreiber hier in seinem bett ist ein
öffentliches bad da habe ich also
teilweise schon erlebt auf dem
hausverbot ausgesprochen haben und dann
haben wir diese leute entsprechen dann
wieder rein geklagt da rein also nochmal
das ist ein bisschen sensibel zu
behandeln das thema ich kann also nicht
jeden aussperren aber wie gesagt ihr
müsst mehr guten deckung durch die
politik bekommen und wenn ich sehe was
da manchmal antwort die verschließt die
augen vor den problemen die wir unten
vor ort haben und lassen unsere kollegen
damit alleine sitzt das haben wir von
radiant schon mal ja und das hat sich im
moment trotz corona krise nichts
geändert warum weil die politik nicht
ins freibad geht
das würde ich auch sagen ich habe also
wenig politiker schon geredet die
freiwilligen sind die aber mit großen
bunten ohne anstehen wenn irgendwas wird
danke für das gespräch hierbei bild
läufer hat seinen vielen dank